yeah welcome to this video playing Bucky
who becky i never played this this guy
this new player lets me just check it
not really new probably not a frequent
play on the icc k that some dough for
the nums 093 is quite flexible answer
that can be recommended for white so one
of the interesting now alternatives
sideline to that to the Maine moose yeah
g3 is the normal muth quite weird his
thinking very long a long time for
theoretical models yeah just 97 on and
not sure could also always think about
taking first but this seems okay okay
God fields a bit bit strange to meet her
play d 5 I take only six and
strengthened black center but ok it's
not not a big deal probably yeah I
wasn't sure maybe night f5s also
possible but okay just back to c6
setting up on a normal formation yeah
this is one issue my dogs class him yet
d5 I was thinking about you fire but the
center can really come on to some some
serious pressure Jim but we should be
six is not particularly great to face
okay let's do that it's some possibly
very risky
now yeah because of that amongst others
yeah this is some very um very dangerous
for me okay takes only have six and then
probably 9 25 mm yeah but this is so
terrible not sure got Queenie 50 i can
probably take and play queen bee three
just winning the spawn this could be the
the simple justification maybe I should
have gone to d6 them okay but it's not
not so clear anyway I wonder why is not
taking okay yeah yep this was some one
point
don't know probably probably a bishop d5
was my idea of course but that he is
playing could be five or something and
maybe maybe I can answer look at five
it's not so bad I want to get rid of
this bishop it's a terribly strong piece
and if he exchanges quindi 50 I am upon
down but at least them yeah I'm
attacking a two and and possibly e to
just take take on a to H is not so
important
yeah pull down and it's not not great
yeah I should have played a queen d 6
probably taking us nonsense um ok I take
the upon
yeah quite a quite problematic endgame
you have four against two some big edge
unfortunately I can love ya is coming to
see to this an additional problem is got
a very very good pawn structure without
any any weaknesses I can of course still
continue it's not like I am I need to
resign or anything but it's it's closely
sorry closed maybe still putting
pressure on the B porn helps pressure is
a big word but at least two were to
annoy him there maybe it's not
completely easy
now it's not so so evident how I should
cover the be porn enter and make any
headway
yeah I don't don't see a such a
clear-cut approach as well I don't see
it
check yeah like I caught up on the clock
still trying to defend let's try to
exchange porns this is always always
helpful yeah better better prevent the
rook from entering jack
I morning this one check
can you believe that I believe yeah this
was nicely played I have still in
trouble him and they can he could have
probably played at five and and stuff
like that at some point out rook rook
away before was was nonsense f5 no wins
and what he did probably as well now
okay 14 seconds difficult who cage three
as I said wrong but right it's um it's
not not so easy in 14 seconds he always
was in trouble him this end game but it
wasn't so also also completely easy to
to make progress after i blundered this
is this stuff here you need to go to the
six this is now so is quite quite
annoying to defend gravity plate this
this egg came nicely this is a big big
edge and okay at first he didn't really
make any progress but then the need of
this nicely yeah thanks for watching